le cac schneider pourrait bien voir
pierre arditi récompensé d'un molière du
comédien
la pièce a été coproduite par le théâtre
montansier de versailles deux autres
créations sont nommés les femmes
savantes et réparer les vivants c'est
une satisfaction pour nous parce que
c'est des spectacles que nous avons
accompagné coproduit et qui sont en plus
on va dire le reflet exact de ce que
nous faisons ce projet c'est
d'accompagner des artistes dans leur
processus de création de les accompagner
on va dire en écoute en finance
quelquefois en répétition en temps de
plateau de les aider en termes de
communication afin de vraiment de les
porter sur sur ce qu'est la jeunesse
d'un spectacle sa préparation ses
répétitions et ensuite son exploitation
le théâtre c'est environ 2 millions
d'euros de budget par saison la moitié
destinée à la création une douzaine est
co produite chaque année le terreau
content c'est d'abord un lieu de
création et ensuite un lieu d'accueil
mais dans la programmation telle quelle
elle n'existe aujourd'hui depuis
notre arrivée c'est à dire la saison 13
14 il ya d'abord deux tiers de
coproduction et un tiers on va dire
d'accueil de spectacles que nous avons
vu et que nous choisissons de programmer
au bia contention un seul en scène un
classique un drame et six nominations
la 29e nuit des molières c'est le 29 mai
prochain